[Music]
here's one I hear a lot how do I get the
most out of a cheap suit a very common
problem first of all never buy cheap buy
the good stuff cheaply when it's on sale
but if this rather excellent piece of
advice comes too late for you remember
you can always reconstruct you're off
the peg purchase let's get to work
a cheap suit is easy to spot dull
plastic buttons are a telltale sign your
tailor will be happy to replace them
with proper buttons in a more
interesting contrasting color like these
here you might even want to splash out
on horn or mother-of-pearl and while
you're at the tailor's shop haven't
check the fit cheap suits often too
roomy so they fit all sorts of body
shapes you've gone to an expert have
them tailor it to you especially the
jacket sleeves they're likely to wide
you want to see the light between your
arms and torso and tragically most men
wear their jacket sleeves too long shirt
cuffs are an important detail give them
at least a centimeter and try French
cuffs they're always a bit classier and
can take a boring suit to the next level
go easy on the cufflinks though you're
not in the Mafia or maybe you are what
are you still doing here
your tailor is waiting off you go
Oh